finally on this Memorial Day morning a
thank you to the service men and women
who have given their lives for our
country that's right today we remember
those who made the ultimate sacrifice on
this Memorial Day our Nate Tanenbaum is
going to close out the show performing
Taps so we hope you have a wonderful
beautiful day a safe day and can spend
some time honoring those that we think
of today all right John Heather and
Jerry so traditionally you expect to
hear Taps on a trumpet and that is
exactly what you'll hear at funeral
services and ceremonies all around the
country but CBS News correspondent Steve
Hartman is urging anyone who's ever
played an instrument to at three o'clock
local time on Memorial Day to get out
and play cops
please
[Applause]
foreign
thank you have a safe holiday
[Music]